درجات الحراره تصل لاكثر من 15 تحت الصفر
في افغانستان فتحت الاعين على اوضاع
الانسانيه بالغه الصعوبه يعيشها الافران
واستفقر متوقع وتضييق حركه طالبا
الاطفال
اضافه الى النظام الصحي المهالك حسب
تقارير
اكثر من 30 شخصا حتفهم خلال الايام
الماضيه بينهم اربعه اطفال في ولاياته
وغور
وفرياد وجوزان نتيجه لموجه البرد القارس
التي تجتاح ارجاء افغانستان وسطه توقعات
بان تتحول الامور لسدار يو اسوا واستحمال
انخفاض درجات الحراره بشكل كبير وتساقط
الامطار والثلوج وفق توقعاته هيئه الارصاد
يتبع لطالبات
ما قد يحول دون وصول المساعدات والمنظمات
الاغاثيه للمحتاجين حسب مكتب الامم
المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه في
افغانستان اضافه الى عراقيل عده تقول
المنظمه ان قوانين حركه طالبان احد اهم
مسبباتها
تاثر بسبب حظر طالبان عمل النساء في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه والنتيجه لمواد غير
الصالحه للتدفئه التي يستخدمها معظم
الافغان بسبب الفقر توفي عده اشخاص نتيجه
اختناقهم بالمواد المحروقه والغاز
باغلاق الوصول الى المناطق النائيه في
افغانستان حيث يوجد بالفعل نقص في الادويه
والمواد الغذائيه وقد تضررت الافتارات من
المحاصيل الشتويه بشده امام الوقوف حكومه
حركه طالبه عاجزه عن التعامل مع الموقف
ماديا ولوجستيه